qu'est ce que cette épidémie de
coronavirus de moderne à vos yeux
alors le propre des théories de
l'effondrement c'est de mettre en
évidence la vulnérabilité nos sociétés
au regard économiques logistiques de
leur dépendance au pétrole notre
dépendance au crédit est aussi la
mondialisation des circuits de
production de consommation dont il a été
question donc dans cette optique
évidemment qu'on peut voir un virus mais
je dirai au même titre que une éruption
volcanique
1 une grande panne généralisée
d'électricité ou un piratage ou un
problème dans l'espoir financière on
peut le voir comme un déclencheur de ce
qu'on appelle l'effet domino pour moi en
toc romancière finalement c'est pas
tellement coronavirus en tant que tel
qui va m'intéresser sait plus ce qui
révèle justement des fragilités d'une
société qui en temps ordinaire se croit
toute puissante
[Musique]